Trascrizione: Cecilia Negri
Revisore: Denise RQ
(Suono di campanacci)
(Applausi)
(Suono di campanacci, voci)
Sono un fotogiornalista
e un fotografo documentarista.
Ho realizzato reportage
in diversi paesi del mondo
e, negli ultimi anni, sono tornato
ad interessarmi all'Italia.
Sono interessato a un'Italia arcaica
che in alcuni luoghi resiste,
nonostante tutto.
Ha tradizioni importanti,
vengono tramandate
e portate avanti, con orgoglio e passione,
dalle giovani generazioni.
Per tre anni, ho lavorato
a un progetto documentario
sul carnevale di Schignano,
sulle montagne del lago di Como.
Questo progetto nasce col preciso intento
di confrontarmi col mio primo
"long-term project",
nella tradizione del
fotogiornalismo documentaristico.
Cercavo un lavoro intimo,
che soltanto questo tipo
di approccio lento può offrire.
Schignano è un paese
di circa mille abitanti,
situato nella valle di Intelvi,
sulle montagne del lago di Como.
Ed è teatro, già dalla fine del '700,
di un carnevale tanto intimo,
quanto unico e sentito.
Carnevale che un tempo sanciva
il momento, per gli emigranti,
di ripartire verso le terre del lavoro,
nelle nazioni europee limitrofe.
E che era quindi una sorta
di festa dell'addio.
E con passare degli anni
è riuscito a mantenere
e preservare il suo spirito,
diventando una vera e propria metafora
dell'emigrazione dalla Lombardia povera.
L'iconografia di questo carnevale
nasce dalla dualità,
più complementale che rivale,
come avete visto, dei "bei" e i "brut"
e si sviluppa poi
in numerosi altri personaggi.
Ho approfondito il carnevale
e le sue simbologie
ed ho scoperto un mondo
di tradizioni, uno stile di vita unico,
una realtà che mi è sembrata,
al primo impatto,
assolutamente impenetrabile.
Ma questa comunità, fiera ed orgogliosa,
mi ha concesso uno straordinario accesso
all'intimità di situazioni
normalmente precluse agli stranieri.
E ho svolto un lavoro estremamente intimo.
Questo carnevale ha una valenza
molto più importante
di un carnevale normale,
in quanto è la vera chiave d'accesso
a una comunità molto coesa e solitaria
che vive e dà vita al carnevale
come la sua espressione più importante,
più significativa e più antica.
Più che una festa popolare,
è una vera e propria opera teatrale:
spontanea, anarchica, selvaggia,
senza regole nè leggi scritte,
che sopravvive solamente
grazie agli abitanti che la animano
e agli artigiani che scolpiscono
le favolose maschere in noce.
Il mio obiettivo era di realizzare
un libro fotografico,
ma per farlo ho deciso di non affidarmi
a un editore consolidato.
Ho scelto di fondare
la mia piccola casa editrice.
Da qualche anno, infatti,
mi interesso di crowdfunding.
Il crowd-funding
è un sistema di raccolta fondi
che nasce e si sviluppa negli Stati Uniti
e che ultimamente si sta
diffondendo anche in Italia.
Un sistema di finanziamento
condiviso dal basso,
che permette di muovere risorse e persone
che sponsorizzano idee e progetti,
che senza di loro
non potrebbero essere realizzati.
Ho sponsorizzato
il lavoro di altri fotografi
e sono principalmente interessato
alle auto-produzioni editoriali.
Mantenendo
una totale autonomia editoriale
si possono realizzare
libri veramente speciali,
con carte e materiali
estremamente all'avanguardia,
e soprattutto di una qualità incredibile,
che raramente viene utilizzata
dalle normali case editrici.
Uno dei vantaggi essenziali
del crowd-funding
è che, oltre a permettere
ai giovani editori
di produrre autononomamente i propri libri
sfruttando canali Internet
consolidati ed autorevoli,
consente di avere immediatamente
una diffusione mondiale.
Infatti sono molto felice del fatto
che il mio crowd-funding sia finito
molto prima del previsto,
in quanto ho raggiunto l'obiettivo
con un mese d'anticipo
rispetto ai tre che avevo preventivato.
Ed ho chiuso il funding al 112 percento,
con un finanziamento di più di 13.000 €.
Il crowd-funding conserva, a mio avviso,
la poetica della partecipazione;
cioè permette alle persone veramente
di partecipare a un progetto,
diventandone parte.
Io, infatti, continuo ancora oggi
a tenere aggiornati i miei funders,
nel senso che ogni minimo particolare,
ogni passaggio del mio progetto
viene poi comunicato ancora adesso,
nonostante il libro sia stato realizzato.
Il preciso intento del mio lavoro
è di richiamare alla responsabilità comune
di preservare la memoria
di individui, popoli e tradizioni.
E infatti sono molto fiero del fatto
che l'unicità, la particolarità
del mio crowd-funding,
rispetto a tutti gli altri,
è che abbia raccolto molto più successo,
molto più sostegno nel mondo reale
che attraverso i social network.
Il risutato di questi tre anni di lavoro
è il Libro "A Winter's Day".
Una favola vitale, selvatica, ruvida;
una favola nera, potente ed ipnotica.
Che svela il volto nascosto di un paese
che ancora ospita, e nasconde,
la follia tribale,
e tutta la carica eversiva,
di un carnevale delle origini.
Grazie.
(Applausi)